if you stand up to the mob if you do the
right thing if you say the truth if you
stand up straight with your shoulders
back if you clean your room and if you
don't fear them you might actually get
stronger you might actually put some
order into the world like this guy it
looks like i'm faced by an overwhelming
opposition but simply not true i just
wrote an article for the telegraph which
was the most devastating article i could
write i thought i was done for by
writing it i basically called for the
jailing of the butchering surgeons who
are doing
gender reassignment surgery so-called on
minors
and
i called the american psychological
association a pack of spineless cowardly
liars and that's pretty
cut and dried i would say and
all of the comments are positive and so
there's a tiny minority of people who
take issue with what i say from time to
time and they're very noisy and many of
them are journalists especially female
british journalists as it turns out but
what that seems to manifest itself in
in the public domain is nothing i've had
no protests to speak of on this tour
we've gone to 60 cities i think in three
months
a handful of protesters
that's it speak the truth follow reality
don't fear the opposition that's how you
reveal their hypocrisy
but not just that that is how
you build the new world that we're all
trying to get to that's how you build
the bridge to get to the other side of
this thing and i can tell you after
being at the sunshine summit here in
florida over the weekend we are building
that bridge right here we're building
the new promised land right here
and i'm thrilled and honored to be right
in the thick of that and wherever you
are watching this whether you are in
canada
with trudeau or whether you're in
california with newsome and i will put
some money in the jar for that um you
got to figure out what you got to do
because nobody's going to save you
but yourself